- Well I haven't seen you.
I went to go visit
"Superstore" with the teachers.
- That's right, Oh my gosh it was so cute.
We were waiting and we were
in the middle of shooting,
and so they're like "Oh just
go over to the other stage
"and wait for Kelly Clarkson
to come and surprise
"all these music teachers."
But the cameras are on
us, we're all ready to go,
we're waiting.
And America just turns to me,
and I had no idea what was going on.
And she was like
"Are we suppose to pretend
we're not losing our minds
"that we're about to meet Kelly Clarkson?"
- Are you serious?
- (Lauren) Yeah. She played
it off so well right?
- Oh my God, she played it off so well
I wouldn't of even known she knew a song.
- Oh no, she's obsessed.
- What!
- Oh yeah, yeah, like legit.
And literally you'd
come in and she was like
"Hi" (mumbles) or whatever.
And then she turned to me and
be like (silently mouths).
- Oh my God, she kept her cool so well.
- Towards the end you
said something about like
"You guys should all come visit
us on the show some time."
and she literally, I don't
think you heard her, she went
"Yeah and you'll be friends."
(laughing and applause)
Oh my God, it was so cute, legit.
- Have you ever,
that just blows my mind I didn't know,
have you ever just lost
it when you met someone?
And you were like,
"Wait that was not a cool moment."
- Oh yes.
- Me too.
- So many times.
I think the most memorable would be,
this was my first movie
role I ever booked,
it was in a film called
"Lars and the Real Girl"
starring Canada's
sweetheart, Ryan Gosling.
- Oh that's how I know,
I was like "I know that movie."
- So, I'm Canadian
and I was still living
in Canada at the time.
So, it was like day one
of the entire production,
it wasn't just my first day,
'cause I had a smaller part,
it's the first day of everything.
So there's kind of a
buzz around everybody,
'cause I know all the
other smaller part actors,
we all know each other, and we're like
"Oh my gosh, Ryan Gosling,"
like "What's this gonna be?"
And then he shows up and he
had gained a bunch of weight
for the role and had grown this mustache.
- That's the day the "Notebook" died.
(laughing)
- Yeah 100%.
And so,
But there's like a hush around us
'cause it's Ryan Gosling
and even with everything
you're still like "Oh my God, come on."
and so we did a couple of rehearsals
and then we were being sent
back to our trailers as happens
and I was walking in
front of a friend of mine,
a lady names Aurora,
and I turned back as she was
talking to me and she was like
"Oh my Gosh, even with the
weight, even with the mustache,
"he's so hot!"
But what she didn't know was Ryan Gosling
was right behind her.
And I wanted to be a good friend
but I was also like,
I can't show him that I'm showing her so,
my way of handling this
was just speeding up.
I was like, I just gotta
walk as fast as I can.
And I'm like, "Aha, aha."
And I'm walking fast and I'm walking fast
and I get to a door, and I
go to push through the door,
and I hit it, 'cause it was a pull!
- Oh.
- And so I smash into this door so hard,
and I turn around to see Ryan Gosling
in full costume, full
get up, method actor,
super serious, just laughing,
just outward laughing at me.
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah, that was a low.
That was a low.
(laughing).
- Have you ever done that Jerry?
Have you ever just lost it?
- Embarrass myself
in front of--
- embarrass yourself like--
- yeah usually every morning at 10:00 a.m.
(laughing)
in front of a whole nation.
- Sure, sure
- So I'm used to humiliation.
I've made a career out of it.
- Way to turn that around.
- Yeah
- Exactly.
I embarrassed myself in
front of Meryl Streep,
in front of the nation, yeah.
I didn't know people were filming.
And I didn't know she was gonna be there,
and she's probably scared of me.
- No.
- It's fine,
everything's fine.
- Everything's fine
- But I...